[Musique]
qu'est-ce qui te définit je te pose la
même question
j'ai demandé avant
Fred n'importe quoi pour ma fille
madame Michaels m'a demandé de vous
donner ça
désolé madame personne n'entre mon mari
travaillait ici j'aimerais pouvoir lui
parler ça fait 24 heures que je n'ai pas
de nouvelles de Wen
où est mon père j'en sais rien qu'est-ce
que c'est
[Musique]
est-ce que ça va j'arrive pas à croire
ce qu'elle nous arrive
n'est pas celui que vous croyez pourquoi
vous parlez de mon mari comme d'un
brillant cerveau criminel je ne peux pas
te dire ce que ton père a fait mais je
sais qu'il est il m'a menti il a disparu
du jour au lendemain je veux savoir la
vérité que je te promets qu'on va le
retrouver
tu dois quitter Austin maintenant vous
avez eu ça dites-moi qui vous envoie
maintenant
sa belle-fille sont en danger de mort il
est au procureur ce qu'il y a quelque
chose que tu me caches il faut
[Musique]
qu'on